élémentaire mon cher watson salue
aujourd'hui pour l'avant dernière vidéo
de l'année je vous propose deux énigmes
à la sherlock holmes c'est une voix un
petit peu bizarre parce que je suis de
plus en plus malade et je suis en train
de perdre ma voix le mot talent blog
aura eu raison de la santé
trois choses rapide avant de lancer les
deux énigmes première chose n'oubliez
pas nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
si vous voulez participer aux prochaines
vidéos parce que je suis en train de
préparer des choses avec vous vous avez
les liens dans la description
deuxième chose si vous êtes abonné
n'oubliez pas de cliquer sur la cloche
pour être notifié des prochaines vidéos
puisque je ne sais pas encore
précisément quand est ce que vont sortir
les premières vidéos de janvier que vous
ne les ratez pas les troisièmes chose
demain c'est la dernière vidéo du défi
d'une vidéo par jour pendant un an du
mandat le blog des filles qu'on est sur
le point de réussir je crois j'avais
pris deux engagements au cours de
l'année en répondant à diverses blague
comme quoi j'allais chalet expliquer
comment devenir invisible de la dernière
vidéo puisque je vais faire et on
m'avait mis au challenge au mois de
février de me mettre à nu dans la
dernière vidéo
si je passais les cent mille abonnés
donc demain demain quoi bon bref les
énigmes
enfilez votre casquette de sherlock
holmes prenez votre plus belle pipe et
résolvez des énigmes
la première énigme c'est que la soeur du
docteur watson a deux enfants est l'un
des deux enfants est un garçon je vous
pose la question chère détective
quelle est la probabilité je parle bien
de la probabilité que le deuxième en
france soit une fille vous pouvez me
répondre en fractions où vous pouvez
aussi me répondre en pourcentage si vous
êtes sûrs et certains la réponse ne
mettez pas dans les commentaires puisque
je vais donner les réponses et la fin de
la vidéo faudrait pas spolier les autres
par contre
mettez sherlock vous mettez juste
sherlock dans les commentaires mais
peut-être
arriverez-vous mieux ou moins bien à
résoudre la deuxième énigme
ça ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
viennent de s'abonner salue les nouveaux
gens c'est un petit gadget de noël que
je me suis offert ya pas de place pour
un produit c'est mais avec mes sous mais
ça fait bien rigoler la deuxième énigme
est beaucoup plus triste puisque nous
allons devoir résoudre ensemble ce qui a
tout l'air d'être un suicide
plongez vous dans l'époque de sherlock
holmes à vous permettra de voir le décor
d'avoir plus d'informations peut-être
pour résoudre cette énigme
en tout cas il s'agit de d'une jeune
femme qui s'appelle là tu n'aimes là tu
n'aimes à 32 ans elle est mariée à la
pas encore d'enfants et elle a été
retrouvée morte dans sa chambre
c'est pas très gai dans la chambre il y
avait une cheminée à gaz qui était
reliée au chauffage central c'était très
courant à cette époque et alors que ce
soit bien clair le gaz était branché
mais ils n'étaient pas à lui mais
pourtant pas relancer le gaz qui est à
l'origine de la mort y aura une autopsie
de fait qui permettra sûrement de
confirmer ça mais on en est quasiment
certain alors le truc c'est que la mère
de là tu n'aimes nous a précisé que
c'était impossible que sa fille se
suicider n'était pas suicidaire elle
avait un super moral et une belle au
choix de vivre alors que la police elle
pense que c'est un suicide bon sherlock
six ans que vous êtes vous avez
peut-être trouvé une autre piste surtout
que je vais vous donner quand même
quelques précisions mais il n'y avait
pas un papier
vous savez un petit papier un petit mot
que malheureusement beaucoup laissent
quand ils mettent fin à leurs jours
ça c'est très étonnant et les fenêtres
de la chambre après un petit examen
minutieux que j'ai fait pour vous les
fenêtres de la chambre était fermée de
l'intérieur est hermétiquement closes
elle était parfaitement intact elles ont
pas été forcé il n'y avait rien de
louche dessus comme la porte d'ailleurs
j'ai bien regardé la porte elle était
fermée à clé et de l'intérieur en plus
on était obligé de la défoncer pour
l'ouvrir donc ça veut dire que la plaie
mais tu es tout seul dans cette chambre
mais pourtant que ce serait pas un
suicide
lire je sais que c'est un gsm quelle est
la personne coupable je sais même quel
est son mode opératoire
comment la personne à tuiles à thème et
vous est ce que vous avez trouvé c'est
ça la vraie question
si vous avez trouvé dans les
commentaires ne le dit pas encore une
fois laissé le suspense ça peut nous
polluer pas les nouveaux mais vous
pouvez m holmes
juste comme ça en petit commentaire donc
si vous avez trouvé 2 vous mettez
sherlock holmes si vous avez trouvé
quand vous mettez charlotte si vous avez
trouvé le deuxième vous mettez route est
alors maintenant nous allons passer aux
réponses donc si vous ne voulez pas
avoir la réponse tout de suite
vous quittez si la vidéo et vous
reviendrai plus tard quand voudraient
vérifier votre réponse et sinon
attention je vais la donner dans
quelques secondes
attention c'est parti pour les réponses
première ligne quelle est la probabilité
que la soeur du docteur watson est une
fille comme deuxième enfant en fractions
ces deux sur trois est donc en
pourcentage c'est à peu près 60 7% et là
je vous entends derrière l'écran dire
maintenant c'est une chance sur deux en
fait c'est 50% de chance non c'est bien
deux sur trois en fait en probabilités
il faut prendre toutes les possibilités
donc en possibilités d'enfants qu'elle
ait pu avoir ça aurait pu faire un
garçon est un garçon ou une fille et un
garçon ou un garçon et une fille ou une
fille et une fille une fille est une
fille on l'éliminé d'entrée parce qu'on
sait déjà qu'elle un garçon sur les deux
il reste donc garçon garçon garçon fille
ou fils garçons et dans ces trois
possibilités il ya deux possibilités où
il ya fille donc c'est bien deux chances
sur trois possibilités tessa les probas
et si jamais vous étiez tomber dans le
piège de une chance sur deux 50% vous
pouvez me mettre une insulte gentille
dans les commentaires une gentille faut
pas exagérer non plus
réponse de la deuxième énigme alors oui
c'est le mari qui a assassiné sa femme
malheureusement c'est pas très sympa de
près c'est comme ça donc notre cher là
tu m'aimes est allé se coucher avant de
se coucher elle a allumé sa cheminée au
gaz une fois que là tu n'aimes s'est
endormi son mari a coupé le gaz au
niveau de l'arrivée centrale
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'avait pas besoin de
pénétrer dans la chambre il a coupé le
gaz donc ça est un lâche milk donc plus
de flamme donc le feu s'est éteint et
c'est là où ça devient intéressant une
fois que le feu s'était éteint le mari a
rallumé le gaz au niveau de l'arrivée
centrale donc le yas s'est propagée dans
la pièce un peu comme le bruit que
ferait un camion poubelle juste devant
ma fenêtre pendant que je fais
le gars s'est propagé dans toute la
pièce et a asphyxié cette pauvre lattes
même sens que le marine d'appeler de
maîtrise argent mais en même temps il a
essayé de faire le meurtre parfait mais
nous l'avons démasqué d'ailleurs il ya
une troisième ligue dans cette énigme je
veux pas vous la dire s'il ya il ya un
c'est pas vraiment une énigme et il ya
un petit truc particulier dans cette
énigme un petit clin d'oeil ou si vous
l'avez trouvé où ça en fait des choses à
se dire aujourd'hui comme d'habitude si
cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
lalique et où vous abonner et rendez
vous demain à 15 heures
là haut
[Musique]